oh that hang me wouldn't they
Take Me Out breaks the road and hang me
in the Square
would it be the first time would it
oh is that where they hung your father
sorry subject yeah I'm gonna say those
are he's provoking him so much in the
sea
yeah they're just bastards they're so
handsome so do you think the star fact
unit could have been like a test like
does he really want that Starbucks unit
no yeah no I think he I think it's
literally like he was looking for Andor
Andor is the commodity because remember
like I mean I think like when he tells
Bix your guy wants to beat me to me that
is the clear indication that like Stone
Skarsgard has been scouting him like a
major league Scout pointing that radar
gun
add Cassie and Andor and he knows way
more about Andor than Andor knows that
he knows you know what it is is uh uh
Lutheran is Willy wonko he hid golden
tickets throughout the Galaxy to find
someone to take over the Rebellion for
him and now andor's got the gold
it's yours Charlie all of it and or you
know what happened to the rebel who got
everything he always wanted he lived
happily ever after until the Death Star
nuked him
I guess he does ride up in an elevator
at one point in Rogue one doesn't he
does that's the walk evader up that
scarif uh control antenna oh my God
somebody get out there and make the fan
art for us please sideways
ah welcome back to new rock stars Star
Wars and or episodes one two and three
introduce Cassian Andor as a refugee
turn cop killer turn reluctant Rebel
join in the mysterious Luther how long
has Lutheran been researching and or to
groom this new Rebel Spy what has been
uh part of his plan could this uh star
path unit not really be all it's cracked
up to be well you'll get your answers
when you fix this and don't door
I'm in I'm going with it yeah I'm going
with it I'm into this is Wookie leaks
it's our weekly reaction to the latest
in Star Wars and now our official after
show for Andor on Disney plus I'm here
with Tommy bechtold and Tommy it is so
good to be back with you I mean I've
missed you I've gotten to see you in the
meantime but it's just not the same
without our weekly meetings may I try
something you'll get your answers no if
and or buts about it
I love it every week I think we'll have
to go with a new one right
my wife said she was either going to
leave me and or invite a third person
into our relationship uh uh
[Laughter]
since we're both improvisers I think we
have to say
um always practice yes and or just
bulldoze your way through a scene
together sweet sweet laughs baby just
shout out I'm the flying elephant I'm
the flying elephant no one can stop you
I mean I remember that Harold Tommy you
brought the house down with that move we
needed literally that the theater
collapsed upon itself like the first
episode of vinyl with Bobby Carnival
deep cut
[Laughter]
um hey I just want to say this show
Andor is the Star Wars content I didn't
know that I needed I love it so much I
uh truly do think it is my favorite
live-action Star Wars thing that's been
on Disney plus oh yeah um it's it's just
you remember when we watched the
Mandalorian first episode before grogu
showed up in that bassinet and it
honestly felt like we don't these are
all strangers we don't know any of these
characters we don't know if they're
gonna have any consequence to the
broader fate of the Star Wars universe
and I just kind of love that now I loved
it on a different level when girl who
showed up but like for those first 22
minutes I was like totally down for what
it was going to be and that's kind of
what Andor feels like and I I truly love
it it feels so refreshing there's been a
lot of debate online about like does
Star Wars or all media need what we call
Easter eggs and what first off I would
say people who are saying the show
doesn't have Easter eggs do not really
know what Easter eggs are and or are not
willing to actually dig and look for
Easter eggs and expect Easter eggs to be
served to them
we'll excavate those yeah exactly we'll
dig movers we'll keep digging and if you
haven't seen my breakdown the first two
episodes I was able to find quite a bit
of like interesting deeper layers of
detail in Star Wars interconnectivity I
think people were like no Easter eggs
it's like well then just translate any
of the orabish that's on screen if
you're not willing to do that then right
maybe don't call yourself a Star Wars
content creator uh you're just someone
who's like just reacts and Recaps
because they're just like willing to
actually you're just a guy with a puppet
that's all yep you're just a guy with a
puppet but I think uh I I really love
this show and I think the first three
episodes I've uh you know I've described
I've compared these to like watching
Spike Lee's do the right thing or the
wire and that and even like there's
definitely some Blade Runner Vibes in
there where it just feels like we're
living in this fantasy world with these
characters but it's like applying this
concept of if this then what else if we
know that there would be an oppressive
Society an authoritarian regime uh where
people are just trying they're all
having to be mobilized to serve this
Empire how would people on the lower
rungs of society get by in these
transactional relationships where
everyone just looks at something in
terms of their bottom line uh where
people are worried that they're going to
be cracked down on by their superiors
the idea of private security it reminds
me of in Aliens the Weyland yutani
Corporation of just Outsourcing
um Outsourcing security uh out in space
it's fascinating to see like what
corporate grunts how they how they
approach their jobs private private
sector Empire workers that are like yeah
we're just like like people that like it
reminds me like analogously to people
and like that over Trump up their jobs
in the real world like it's like these
guys probably like go to like parties
and they're like I work for the Empire
adjacently through a private security
company uh yeah uh and and in a way in
this kind of society everyone works for
the Empire right you know unless you're
a rebel you are somehow feeding the
Empire machine right um so it's just
interesting to see how this has affected
everyone's in society there's like a
famous quote from George R Martin when
he was talking about what he wanted to
do with his Song of Ice and Fire books
compared to what Tolkien did with the
Lord of the Rings trilogy and basically
look like what is the tax policy of the
realm you know that's that's a question
he wanted to explore in his world and
now it feels like we're exploring
exploring what is the tax policy of Star
Wars Universe now I know you're gonna
say well that's what the prequels did
with like the trade Federation and tax
policy but I don't I think that was
discussed as motivations for characters
but he didn't really feel the economic
impact on characters in that world
because we were still focused on Jedi
and and princesses and and uh important
people at the top of all that drama now
we're seeing people who are basically
Anonymous red shirts you know and and
we're seeing how they have to like pick
up work shifts how they have to cover
for each other yeah uh how it feels like
such a lived-in universe uh where
everything is just kind of a transaction
but everything is also life and death
when you're at that level in an
authoritarian Society because like you
know this idea of like the city goes to
sleep early and so you have to have an
alibi squared away because like your
every movement can be tracked but what's
interesting is it's not always tracked
like it's private security it's like
they have to like uh bully each other
into looking at the flight logs yeah
he's like it's gonna take me all night
it's the same as any company you got a
few people that are like barely do their
job and when you barely do your job than
what's expected versus what's delivered
are two very different things you know
like this is like the first Star Wars
show where it's really seemed like
people are actually lazy at their jobs
like in an actual realistic level of
laziness we've seen lazy Stormtroopers
before but we kind of like scoff at that
because it's like why wouldn't you like
wouldn't you be a bit more uh gung-ho
and more of like a Rambo type uh why you
wouldn't be so sleepy on the on the
watch whereas this it's like no these
are the types of jobs where people would
be kind of like lazy and Petty and
annoyed you know and I love that yeah me
too let's go through uh just with a
recap of the episodes and just a
reminder since the first three episodes
of Andor dropped at the same time you
probably have seen this on the channel
at this point we decided to do things a
bit differently my Easter egg breakdowns
for episode one and for episode two are
already on the channel so if you only
had time to watch one or two episodes so
far you could watch those videos right
away we want to do it that way for you
guys and we delayed this looking
League's reaction to all three episodes
to right now and we want to do that so
that fans had a bit more time to watch
all three episodes and you know whatever
the first 24 hours or so so if you um
you know as you saw at the beginning of
this video this reaction is going to
cover everything through the end of
Andor episode three my Easter egg
breakdown of Andor episode 3 will be on
the channel next tomorrow
um so recap episode one takes us back to
five BBY this is five years before Rogue
one as I pointed out my breakdown it's
interesting that they put BBY on screen
that's not something that Star Wars
commonly does and I go into why that's
important in the breakdown but uh Cassie
and Andor is on the planet of morlana
one and he's searching in a brothel
which is just a fascinating setting to
be in in Star Wars uh there's been a lot
of headlines about like oh finally and
or acknowledges the existence of sex and
Star Wars which I think is just like an
overstatement like because like
obviously there are characters who are
hooking up having sex
Padme is pregnant
right so we know it happened there I
understand we didn't show it on screen
but there's also been like expanded
Universal literature there's been other
literature Star Wars movie implies that
like there's like you know whatever
right right I mean just the existence of
like Twilight dancers and slave Leia
like we know that sex is happening on
Jabba's pleasure yet like there's there
is sex in Star Wars uh but uh I'll admit
on Disney plus this is the first time
where it's been so explicit you know the
fact that uh a brothel is there and uh
it just feels like so Noir in a way that
Star Wars rarely is uh and he's
searching for a qunari girl that he
claims is his sister uh but this gets
him in a scuffle with two primor private
security cops and he ends up killing
them both and again I just love the way
this is directed uh like the fact that
like so much is subtext and the way that
uh cop is at first like you killed him
you killed him and then realizes oh you
still have the gun
um we can we can talk our way out of
this we can figure this out and it's a
running theme that I go into in the
breakdown is how so many characters in
this first episode come up with these
alternate version of events just to
cover their ass like everyone on every
level is doing that they have such a
loose relationship with the truth and I
feel so accurate for people living in an
authoritarian Society uh you have to
have a loose relationship with the truth
and Juke the stats and and kind of cover
your ass in these ways
um and everyone is lying through their
teeth constantly so uh Cassian returns
to the plant pharynx where he's greeted
by his adorable stuttering Droid b2emo
uh the fact that the Droid has to like
recharge in order to lie is such a fun
world yes I love it so much he's a b2mo
has my heart already I yeah dear God
release the merchandise uh
this large huge Roomba yeah like I want
that merchandise because it's so hard to
own as a toy yeah it's going to take up
so much space in your room I might it's
gonna make a huge mess I might just make
a shop vac into a b2mo uh like uh
facsimile yep uh so uh we learned from
flashback dreams that Cassian uh used to
be named Casa it was part of an
all-youth tribe of kids on qunari they
speak this unsubtitle language which I
think is so fascinating we don't need to
know what they're saying we can kind of
get it from Context but it creates this
like emotional distance between us like
we're watching like a documentary of
these kids like a photojournalist was
embedded with these kids and he's like I
don't know what they're saying but
here's how they operate like it was just
so cool and he leaves behind the sister
figure as the kids go on to check out a
crash site but back on ferricks we just
get a feel for the town all the blue
collar Community Vibes uh how they break
down Republic airships for scraps to
repurpose for an imperial Fleet uh
Cassie and that's his friend Brasso to
form an alibi Deputy inspector Cyril
Karn tries to dig into the murders but
it's called by a superior to brush it
under the rug to avoid an imperial
Crackdown Cassian asks Bix to call her
contact so he can sell off a valuable
Imperial star path unit Karn goes Rogue
bullies his subordinates and attracting
down the suspect and releases
essentially an APB on a qunari male and
on episode 2 at weidens our look at the
work down on ferrics including this
badass time Grappler in a bell tower
yeah and I pointed out the breakdown
that this actor is one of the starter
Car Guys in Dune oh dogs at another like
he's such an amazing physical actor and
I just love how committed he is with
this Bell that he's ringing Cassie and
stepmom is Marva Andor so his name was
not originally and or he got it from
Marva and she's worried that people will
know now that he's from qunari bix's
boyfriend Tim gets jealous of bix's
Friendship with Cassian and snitches on
Cassie and Primo security Karn teams up
with my favorite character from these
first three episodes yes Linus mosque
what a performance what a voice I called
him Dwight Schrute of morlano one he's
such a Dwight Schrute like yeah no we
need to take our job seriously sir
that's momentum from pockets of
fermenting oh God I I almost thought
that like I was like is he uh is he on
the Rebellion side because he's so over
the top he's so interesting we need more
men like you sir you're doing it the
best sir I wish we could all do it like
you sir I'm on your side completely sir
but doesn't it make sense that um people
in Pre more security private security
would have a guy like this no yeah like
uh kind of like a volunteer Sheriff
essentially who's like so gung-ho it's
the it's the guy and it runs security at
like a local like Carnival that like
deputizes himself like he's like you
know what I'm gonna take this job way
too seriously I'm gonna bring like
pepper spray six flashlights and like
put like a put like a like a squirt gun
and a gun holster and walk around like
this all day exactly yeah he's uh a
major uh Community Watch volunteer vibes
from this a lot of character big Karen
Vibes perfect casting and like he's
older too which is great because he's a
guy who's like missed opportunities in
the past and has just got all this like
yeah old school grandfathered
institutional knowledge like made no
friends after on the force for 20 years
yeah a real piece of work yeah and he's
played by the actor from Chernobyl a lot
of Chernobyl actors including obviously
still in Skarsgard but he's played by
the guy who plays the coal miner who
they make us uh go dig the trench
underneath Chernobyl and he strips down
naked this and he also is in uh the
Batman he plays Commissioner Pete Savage
in the Batman such a great actor I love
that he's having a moment in 2022 so
they lead this raid to ferrics and then
bix's contact Luth and Rael makes his
way to ferrets to meet Cassian and the
qunari flashbacks Casa sees this
abandoned mining Pit and the crash site
where gas victims in separatist uniforms
kill the kids leader uh and then Cassian
turns around not to follow the kids but
to explore the ship and then on episode
three my favorite jump cut where we go
from beat up b2e mode to like nice clean
unstuttery powered up b2emo with Marva
and Clem they are the ones who gas these
separatists to scavenge their ship and
they find Casa as he looks at his
reflection starts smashing up the
separatist ship Bridge uh Marva takes
podiacasa takes him with him Cyril Karn
and mosque's tackpod arrives to ferrics
they begin their Searcher casting
including raiding Marvis home which
pisses off all the locals they're like
she's just an old woman what are you
doing Cassian calls B2 on the calm and
learning card into his position Lutheran
meets Cassian in the factory to
supposedly buy the star path unit but is
actually more curious about Cassian
himself and how he was able to stole it
what kind of man he is and kind of
signals that he knows a lot more about
Cassian than one might think he knows
that it sounds like we're swimming Clem
was hung in the street for some unknown
crime uh Cassian says that one can
Infiltrate The Empire just by playing to
their arrogance
yes I love it I love it and then uh
Lutheran offers Cassian a chance to join
the rebellion and be part of something
bigger are they getting a shootout with
current soldiers they barely Escape they
leave the star path unit behind car in
search pisses off the townspeople they
all go on lockdown they start hitting
this medal to alert each other we great
get this great moment from karna that's
that's the sound of a rebellion you know
like ah like the way these people just
kind of this like that with each other
that Eric when you were talking about it
being like the wire before like to me
when they're all like doing little
clicks and dings to notify everybody
around that there's trouble like 5-0
yeah yeah all the whistles and like yeah
right I thought yeah totally or like the
way if you watch season one of the wire
it's a little dated at this point but
the way that they use burner yeah
beepers yeah to communicate with each
other so that they can't be tracked like
it's such like a clever World building
detail so big skits cuffed Tim
compressing soldiers they shoot him dead
uh Brasso and the other towns people
begin to Riot sabotage an attack pod uh
it's pretty cool to see it all fall
apart so fast Lutheran Cassie and rig an
empty speeder into a bomb she
humiliating Karn luthin escapes with
Cassian and her departure from Barracks
crosscuts with the flashback of Marva
taking Casa off Canary and I just love
this final sequence with all the music
it was just so beautiful to see uh the
casting is essentially someone without a
home and his only that's his only
comfort zone is wherever he's headed
next he's always had this kind of level
of discomfort and it's kind of made him
a perfect Rebel Spy as someone who could
never settle down he's always dragged
off into another uh this essentially
absolutely now let's talk about Lutheran
Royal and how he knows so much about
Cassian Andor his secret Rebel Network
what really happened to cassian's sister
and his stepdad so Tommy let's ask it
what's the big question from these first
few episodes well Eric
I gotta ask you
what is Lutheran's plan door
we're gonna we're gonna make it work
um just reminded everyone about like
where things are currently in Star Wars
we're in five BBY the Rebellion is still
uh kind of in its infancy there is some
stuff going on but things aren't really
organized yet uh we know that early
seeds were planted about 14 years before
this when Senator Monmouth Senator
balorgan and a few other Senators met in
secret at the dawn of the Empire
planning to covertly disrupt the
emperor's actions in a bid to preserve
democracy however possible this is a
deleted scene from Revenge of the Sith
and I wish that they kept it yeah
because it's such an important scene but
we know from canonical literary sources
that bail Organa met Ahsoka Tano a few
years before the events of and or to
enlist her in a Rebel Spy codename
fulcrum of course
um and then around this time around 5
BBY in Star Wars Rebels the Animated
Series the crew of the ghost is starting
to come together actually Leia Organa
has begun to assist in low-level Rebel
operations I think she's now aware that
the Rebellion is happening her parents
finally admitted that to her now we know
from Trailer footage that Lutheran Royal
has some relationship with mon mothma he
wears a different disguise as he works
in an antique shop on Coruscant and we
know that he has a relationship with
sagarrera into partisans because we know
from Trailer footage they meet up at
some point
um so when Bix contacts luthin using
that Morse code-like device in episode
one I think he was actually expecting
her call we know where man has done his
homework and we uh he knew that Cassie
and stepfather and I'm guessing that's
Clem that was more of his partner he
must have been the one who was hung in
the street for some crime and that
touches a nerve with Cassian but I'm
most curious about that Imperial star
path unit because it's supposedly
extremely valuable so much that Bix gets
upset with casting that he was holding
out on her it should not have been this
easy to find if it's this valuable even
for someone just kind of uh strolling in
like they own the place to whatever
Imperial Center where he got it from uh
Lutheran doesn't seem that interested in
it even though Cassian says it can be
used to find every Imperial site with a
nine radial parsecs Lutheran is willing
to leave it behind and he's more Curious
how Cassian got it he's more interested
in the person who stole it than the
object itself uh Cassius methods where
the Empire is weak the the trouble spots
uh and where people he has on the inside
might have been exposed because I think
the Imperial star path unit leak was a
test Tommy and I were joking about it
being like a Golden Ticket yeah Willy
Wonka snuck in throughout uh for people
to find I think there might be some
truth to that I think Lutheran has a
mole inside the Empire who leaked the
star path unit with data that Lutheran
might already know thus why he was
willing to leave it behind I think this
was a test to see whether a criminal
like Cassian could be skilled enough to
steal it and whoever reports back to
Lutheran saying that they found this
golden ticket passes that preliminary
test and now Lutheran is curious what
methods Cassian use because he's part of
a very uh discreet and carefully
orchestrated plan to recruit people it's
hard to recruit people for Rebellion
because you don't know who you're
talking to right so you have to have
people who who come to you essentially
and start to steal stuff and how do you
do that you have someone on the inside
leak this stuff for them to find uh like
if you imagine like Game of Thrones we
remember when in series season two when
Tyrion Lannister told different pieces
of information to uh three different
people just to see where the leak would
come out uh and I think that's a version
of what casting is doing here I think
Cassian uh or I think it's a version of
what Luton is doing here and I think
Cassian is on his short list already he
has a short list of criminals that might
be good uh recruits for what they have
but they're afraid to approach them just
outright because they don't want to get
outed as uh obviously Lutheran is
someone who has to like wear disguises
in order to access he has
um so I think he has uh put Cassian on a
short list ever since Clem's execution I
think in that moment they're like wait
so there was this adopted son there and
they're criminals still okay all right
just put them on the list yeah we'll see
if we'll see if he finds his way back to
us yeah um and just so that everyone
knows yeah this series doesn't seem that
big on Easter eggs or cameos I doubt
we'll see Ahsoka Tano show up as another
one of Lutheran's operatives maybe names
like fulcrum or captain cindula or the
ghost might get referenced in a small
way but I think I think one thing is for
sure that Luther knows a lot more uh
than we thought and I think that this
Imperial star path unit is a total red
herring really the more valuable thing
was a new operative and they had to be
very careful about how they recruited
them yeah what do you think Tommy I
agree I think uh as as you know Eric I
am your Padawan and you are my master
but I uh or maybe I'm your Sif uh
Apprentice but uh either way I was about
halfway to where you got I thought the I
thought the the star path was uh uh
was a test I did not think Lutheran uh
already knew the information that is
brilliant if he already knew everything
that was on that unit and then still was
like go find it for me I think it makes
perfect sense though because I mean it
really I mean the the entire most of the
time of of that we see the Rebellion on
screen they are The Underdogs they don't
have the technology they don't have the
gear what they have are the people they
have the people that are willing to go
farther are willing to sacrifice it all
are willing to risk it all for the cause
that is what makes it a rebellion and
not an Empire right an Empire is stocked
up it's the Yankees they got Aaron judge
they got all I'm gonna lose all our fans
with that it's a good sports team with a
lot of superstars the Rebellion they're
Scrappy they do a lot of bunting
stealing spitting in the eyes of the
catcher so yeah I think that that makes
perfect sense and I love the idea that
he actually knew every piece of
information on it which would also
explain why when things were falling
from the ceiling and everything even
before then when it was just a little
bit dangerous he's like who cares about
it forget about it leave it leave it
yeah yeah so yeah I'm with you yeah I
think um just keep an eye on this star
path unit remember they did leave it
behind and now there's going to be a
huge investigation on ferricks like the
fact that it's unclaimed unless someone
can like grab it up real quick and hide
it like if that gets entered into
evidence it's gonna be a very big uh
controversy for whatever investigates
this like it's like basically saying
like wait there was a briefcase full of
nuclear codes right at this crime scene
how did this get out there were files
with important nuclear code information
just hanging out somewhere random this
story is too Fantastical Eric we should
probably talk about our sponsors
we probably should move on and uh if
world is too insane to get through
without some help
s for you better help is here to help
how we care for our minds affects how we
experience life so it's important to
invest time and Care into keeping them
healthy there are plenty of ways to
support a healthy brain like learning a
new language or taking power naps but
there's also better help online therapy
better help is online therapy that
offers video phone and even chat only
therapy sessions so you don't have to
see anyone on camera if you don't want
to it's much more affordable than in
person therapy and actually Tommy began
using betterhelp recently Tommy you want
to talk about that you know Eric I just
I think about I thought about my brains
and I thought about my health and I
thought about my well-being and I said
you know what let's just spit this out
to someone else and see if they can
unscramble it and make it their own star
path unit of information and so yeah and
I gotta say I keep saying this on the
break room and I'll say it here too
I am not necessarily the most motivated
or functional person when it comes to
taking care of yourself this was so easy
so easy to sign up for so quick to turn
around you know once I entered in just a
few bits of information about myself you
know you can go as personal or you know
you can you can be vague if you're not
yet comfortable sharing as you like
they'll match you up with someone that
that is a good fit and my FIT was great
I'm still working with her she's
wonderful uh it's been a great
experience and so for someone like me
that really needs a little push and not
necessarily is going to do the heavy
lifting do especially when it comes to
therapy to to you know make sure that
it's perfect better help I could not
speak uh more highly of it and here's
what I think is cool for our uh for our
viewers they can get 10 off their first
month at betterhelp.com slash Wookie
that's better
h-e-l-p.com slash Wookie so enter our
code it helps us it makes better help
keep sponsoring us and it also helps you
to get the 10 off I mean that's pretty
great that's great thank thank you for
sharing that Tommy and yeah that sounds
like an awesome thing to uh to check out
absolutely
um all right let's get back to talking
about this episode yes um a mystery that
uh gets introduced in episode one and
not really explored in episode two or
three that much is this idea of
cassian's sister or at least like the
the younger female companion that he
considers his sister whom we see in the
flashback in episode one he's ex he's
looking for her in his brothel and
qunari on in episode two what do you
think's the story there Tommy what
happened to this sister I you know he he
left so abruptly it's one of those
things where the Star Wars universe and
the Star Wars the Star Wars Universe the
way that it often plays out makes me
think she works for the Empire you know
what I mean like somehow the next round
of people that came in the next round of
adults that came into that tribe were uh
Empire forces uh Imperial forces or or
that tribe you know is still around as
adults you know it has scattered
throughout and created their own you
know Syndicate of criminals maybe it's
another crime syndicate I think there's
so many fascinating ways for it to go
and you're right it was kind of left
to marinate after the first episode you
know we won't get to know until we get
to see future episodes but
yeah I mean you know it's it's it's uh
it's a curious thing I I tend to be more
I tend to be inclined to predict she is
probably with the Empire but uh that's
just my personal prediction yeah you
know it's interesting this is really the
inciting incident like up until this
point Cassian could have lived his life
in relative uh I mean he was a scrapper
he was a you know he had like a criminal
record but this is the moment he outs
himself as being from qunari and that's
what like causes people to find him on
varics he accidentally kills two cops
like that's this is the inciting
incident he may he slipped up he made
the mistake of going to look for his
sister so this is a very very important
thing to him that he finds her uh and I
I think even though the it seems like
the plot whisks away from that I think
that is going to be his guiding
principle that the this season
absolutely must readdress uh and now
that he's swept up in this world of the
rebellion and is going to be joining
these Rebel plots I think that's got to
be something important by the end of it
he's gonna like run back into her maybe
she is uh she's someone who is
um imprisoned in one of these uh work
camps or something like that
um well Bonnie gets mentioned in these
first couple episodes there's like a
raid to obani and we know that that is
the sight of an imperial labor camp
where um where jyn urso gets imprisoned
in Rogue one
um maybe his sister is is in that prison
it was a it seemed like it was a female
prison or at least a cell that generous
it was in was a female cell so um but
like if she worked in this brothel we
don't know if the qunari woman was for
sure his sister like it was implied that
she wasn't so like I don't know why they
would set up another qunari woman
um but like uh yeah maybe she could end
up like being someone in the employee of
uh of an imperial officer you know this
idea of they're so sad fat and satisfied
right like imagine if she is like
someone who's like uh working as like a
server or a bartender or some other kind
of like unfortunate position working for
some other kind of like you know is
there going to be like a taken scenario
oh yeah Cassian has to go into some
pleasure yacht yeah and Savor just by
shooting past someone Jesus Christ I
have a particular such a school and I
will attracted shooting people in the
face they're going to take you
I think like maybe there's gonna be an
opportunity where uh Cassian has an
opportunity to either rescue his sister
from the clutches of some high-level
Imperial officer or Lutheran pressures
him and says we can flip her we can use
her and and he's like I don't want to
use her I want to get her out of this
he's like no we need her in this
position right so talk to her see if
she's willing to join our cause uh I
don't know I think I don't think casting
is going to be to betrayed uh feel to
betrayed by the by the rebels in this
episode because we are in the season
because we know uh where he's gonna end
up at the start of Rogue one he's still
working for mon Mothman everybody so
um yeah we'll see what happens uh maybe
his sister is already a rebel yeah and
she's the one who kind of says like you
know she dies at the end of this season
and she's like but I need you just to
keep fighting in my memory you know yeah
yeah yeah maybe she's the one who
planted the seed with Luth
be maybe oh that'd be cool
um similar question I think we should
talk about I don't know if this is like
an intentional mystery or just like the
way the writing talked about it so in
episode two we see the big mining pit on
Canary and uh when when Cassian gets the
report and someone says what is qunari
they report back to him there was like
an imperial mining disaster and now the
planet is toxic however when that ship
crashes there in the flashback those are
separatists they have the separatist hex
uh logo and that that sets it not during
the age of the Empire but during the
Clone Wars if they're separatists versus
The Republic now it could just be like
these are separatist officers who are
just still wearing this separatist crew
uniform and it's after uh after you know
uh uh Palpatine has declared the the
Empire or something like that there
could be some overlap in the time
periods but it makes me wonder if there
was some other kind of thing that had
happened there after after this uh
mining pit has had been abandoned and
that the Empire maybe took back took
over this area and kept digging and did
something even worse yeah yeah and they
called it an imperial mining disaster
that there was something else some other
kind of War crime that was uh that was
covered up there but where are all the
adults right it's a tribe full of
training so like they got to be the kids
so the workers right that's my adults
were the miners that were killed right
yeah yeah
um so whose fault like do we think that
there was some other kind of like worse
disaster there some kind of cover-up
yeah or maybe maybe you know maybe the
miners were rising up or maybe you know
this show is so so grounded maybe it was
like they tried to unionize or something
you know not to like maybe it was like
they they wanted better wages in the
Empire some overzealous Imperial officer
just mowed them all down and then they
were like oh these kids and like you
know maybe like maybe or maybe they
didn't know about the kids or whatever
or they or they just abandoned the kids
there and then they were like it's toxic
so nobody goes to look oh sure research
what they did yeah I'm super curious to
see what this a being I think there is
more to the story of what happened on
qunari and the fact that so few people
know about qunari I think there was like
kind of a Ministry of truth deal that
they kind of like put up a cover story
in any kind of Records people look up on
qunari it's like well then uh if it's
not in the archives it must not exist
right like I think there's like a
situation where the archives were like
adjusting and one thing that I would
love to see explored on the show is how
information is controlled and it seems
like you know we're going to be meeting
the ISB Anton lessers playing a
character you know like that's I think
the whole idea of how information is
controlled in this Empire is is finally
going to be exploded star wars and I
can't wait for that yes indeed we will
leave it there for this episode Wookie
leaks and again my Easter egg breakdowns
for episode one and episode two already
on the channel go check those out if you
haven't already breakdown of episode
three is coming tomorrow so I'll get
into all the details that you missed
from that you can follow Tommy at Tommy
Bechtel follow me at eavos follow new
rockstars And subscribe Wikileaks
wherever you get your podcast subscribe
to rockstars thank you for watching and
we have specials